Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist always start these podcasts exactly the same way i say that we're in the middle of the world cup marathon because we are and there's no other way but dominic the thing is we don't actually know if we get in the middle do we because we haven't yet worked out the schedule what we do know tom is that this is a podcast about Ecuador. Now, Ecuador's participation in the World Cup, it has been hanging by a thread for quite a while, hasn't it? Because there was some talk of them being kicked out,
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist 每次开始这些播客时，我的开场白总是完全一样的：我说我们正处于世界杯马拉松的中间阶段，因为我们的确身在其中，别无他法。但多米尼克，问题在于，我们实际上并不知道自己是不是真的到了中间，对吧？因为我们还没弄清赛程。汤姆，我们所知道的是，这是一档关于厄瓜多尔的播客。现在，厄瓜多尔参加世界杯的资格，悬而未决已经有一段时间了，对吧？因为之前有一些关于他们被驱逐的讨论，
which you were gutted by because you really wanted to do this podcast. Well, you're an absolute, you have a passion. And you've talked to me about this from the beginning of The Rest is History. You have a passion for Ecuadorian history. And you said you would. Dominic, Dominic, I've been up front throughout this that Latin American history is not my strength. Oh, Tom, don't say that.
这让你感到非常沮丧，因为你真的很想做这期播客。好吧，你简直是，你有着一种热情。而且从《The Rest Is History》开播之初，你就一直在跟我谈论这个。你对厄瓜多尔历史有着极大的热情。而且你说过你会的。多米尼克，多米尼克，我从一开始就很坦率地承认过，拉丁美洲历史不是我的强项。噢，汤姆，别这么说。
So Ecuador, basically, I know two things about Ecuador. The first is it was the name of the 1990s club classic by Sash. You familiar with that? No, I'm not. You weren't strutting your stuff to it? I've learned something, Tom. I've learned something on this podcast. I've educated myself, which is lovely.
所以厄瓜多尔，基本上，我只知道关于厄瓜多尔的两件事。第一件事是它是 90 年代 Sash 的那首俱乐部经典舞曲的名字。你熟悉那首歌吗？不，我不熟悉。你没有伴着它扭动身姿吗？我学到了一些东西，汤姆。我在这个播客里学到了一些东西。我丰富了自己的知识，这很好。
Down at Love Muscle every Saturday night, dancing to this. Right. Ecuador. You know? You don't remember that at all? I hope they cut this, Tom. I really do. Maybe you'd remember it if you heard it.
每周六晚上在 Love Muscle 俱乐部，伴着这首歌跳舞。好吧。厄瓜多尔。你知道吗？你一点都不记得了吗？我希望他们能把这段剪掉，汤姆。我真是这么想的。也许你听了就能想起来了。
I don't know. But the other thing I know about Ecuador, and this is a bit of a cheat, is that a chunk of it was visited by Charles Darwin, namely the Galapagos Islands. Okay. And I know that doing an episode on Ecuador and focusing on Charles Darwin is a bit of a cheat, but that's what I'm doing.
我不知道。但我知道的关于厄瓜多尔的另一件事，这有点像是作弊，那就是查尔斯·达尔文曾去过那里的一部分，也就是加拉帕戈斯群岛。好吧。我知道做一期关于厄瓜多尔并重点关注查尔斯·达尔文的节目有点作弊嫌疑，但这就是我要做的。
So all that talk about you doing the foundation of Quito. I don't know anything about it. In the vice royalty of Nueva Granada. No. Or Dempsey had the Quito, all that stuff. That was a lie. You're not going to do that at all. I'm not going to do that at all, no.
所以关于你讲基多建城的那些长篇大论。我对此一无所知。在新格拉纳达总督辖区。没有。或者德姆西占领基多，所有这些事情。那都是谎言。你根本不打算讲那些。我确实不打算讲那些，没有。
But actually, and this is a sequel to, after Christmas last time, we did the 12 Days of Christmas, didn't we? We did a kind of series of episodes focused on anniversaries. And one of the episodes was the day that Darwin left Plymouth on the Beagle, 27th of December, 1831. And we talked about the backdrop to this famous voyage that he did, which Darwin described as by far the most important event in my life. The Beagle was a survey ship. It was being sent out to basically map the geography of South America. It was planned
但实际上，这是上次圣诞节之后的续篇，上次圣诞节我们做了“圣诞节的 12 天”，对吧？我们做了一系列以周年纪念为主题的节目。其中一期节目讲述的是达尔文于 1831 年 12 月 27 日搭乘“小猎犬号”离开普利茅斯的那天。我们谈到了他这趟著名航行的背景，达尔文将其描述为“我一生中最重大的事件”。“小猎犬号”是一艘测量船。它被派出去绘制南美洲的地理图。原计划
to be a two-year voyage. It ended up being a five-year voyage, complete circumnavigation. And Darwin went on it as a naturalist and geologist, he was preeminently a geologist at this point. That was his main interest. He was less interested in natural history. Although, I mean, he loved it too. He was very keen on beetles. He loved a beetle. Okay.
这是一次为期两年的航行。最后却变成了一次历时五年、完成环球航行的旅程。达尔文作为自然学家和地质学家登上了这艘船，在那个时候，他主要是一名地质学家。那是他的主要兴趣所在。他对自然历史的兴趣相对较少。尽管，我的意思是，他也非常热爱自然。他非常喜欢甲壳虫。他酷爱甲壳虫。好吧。
He was very interested in marine life and he was very good at shooting. So you remember in the Loch Ness episode, we talked about Peter Scott who became a kind of leading conservationist founder of the World Wildlife Fund but he'd begun as a his great pursuit was um was shooting duck and he then became a leading ornithologist and slightly the same thing with Darwin. Coach turned gamekeeper Tom. That he was very good at shooting stuff at uh skinning it at stuffing it all that kind stuff. And so basically he gets signed up. He's
他对海洋生物非常感兴趣，而且他枪法极好。所以你还记得在尼斯湖那一集里，我们谈到了彼得·斯科特，他后来成为了一名杰出的自然保护主义者、世界自然基金会的创始人，但他最初的追求是——他的巨大爱好是——呃，是打野鸭，然后他成为了一名杰出的鸟类学家，达尔文的情况也有些类似。猎人转行成了护林员，汤姆。他非常擅长射杀动物、呃，剥皮、将其做成标本以及所有这类事情。所以基本上，他被招募了。他当时
22 years old. He's a gentleman. He's very much an amateur and he's going on board the survey ship. The plan is that he will be looking at the various, you know, the wildlife, all that kind of stuff. But he's also going as a kind of gentleman companion for the captain of the ship, who's a man named Jamesames fitzroy who is also a young man he's about 26 i think when they when they leave and one of the reasons why that is important is that um fitzroy is quite depressive so he's actually the nephew of lord castlereagh the foreign secretary who kills himself oh yeah yes and a former captain of the beagle had also killed himself because i think it's quite isolating, quite lonely being captain of a ship.
22 岁。他是一位绅士。他很大程度上是一个业余爱好者，他即将登上这艘测量船。计划是他将负责观察各种，你知道的，野生动植物以及所有这类事情。但他也是作为船长的绅士伴侣登船的，船长名叫詹姆斯·菲茨罗伊，他也是个年轻人，他们起航时他大概 26 岁左右。其中一个重要原因是，呃，菲茨罗伊有相当严重的抑郁倾向，实际上他是自杀身亡的外交大臣卡苏利雷勋爵的侄子。哦，是的。是的，而“小猎犬号”的前任船长也自杀了，因为我认为
So essentially their relationship is like Aubrey and Maturin in Master and Commander. So Darwin is basically Paul Bettany in the film. That's his role. And in fact, I guess that that is why in the film they end up going to the galapagos islands which is where we will be going with fitzroy and darwin okay darwin is a wig he's very progressive uh he's not in favor of slavery uh he's a supporter of the reform act which is uh bubbling away in the background as the beagle sets off fitzroy is an absolute diehard
担任一艘船的船长是一件相当孤立、相当孤独的事情。所以本质上他们的关系就像《怒海争锋》里的奥布里和马图林。所以达尔文基本上就是电影里的保罗·贝坦尼。这就是他的角色。事实上，我想这就是为什么在电影里他们最后去了加拉帕戈斯群岛，也就是我们将和菲茨罗伊以及达尔文一起去的地方。好吧，达尔文是个辉格党人，他非常进步，呃，他不支持奴隶制，呃，他是改革法案的支持者，当“小猎犬号”起航时，这个法案正在背景中酝酿。菲茨罗伊是个绝对顽固的托利党人，他，呃，他完全赞成奴隶制，所以这里面有巨大的政治争论空间，但实际上他们相处得相当不错。他们知道他们必须好好相处。是的。所以他们起航了，他们，呃，他们驶向南美洲，达尔文基本上如鱼得水，因为有太多的野生动物供他研究。从一开始，他就发明了一种网，他用它拖网捕捞，捞起各种奇妙的海洋动物来研究。他到达巴西，那里有热带雨林。他描述了走进热带雨林并看到生命那种令人难以置信的繁茂景象。他说，这让他欣喜若狂。在巴塔哥尼亚，他遇到了令人难以置信的化石，即古代哺乳动物的化石，把它们全部打包。但他还，他参与了
tory he um he's all in favor of slavery um so there's a huge scope for political arguments but actually they get on pretty well they know that they've got to get on well yeah and so they set off um they uh they head to south america and darwin basically, he is in clover because there is just so much wildlife for him to get into. Right from the beginning, he invents this kind of net that he trawls and he just picks up all this kind of amazing sea animals that he can inspect. He gets to Brazil, there's the rainforest. He describes going into the rainforest and seeing the kind of incredible luxuriance of life. And it leaves him in an excess of delight, he says. Patagonia, he comes across kind of incredible fossils, fossils of ancient mammals, packs them all up. But he also, he gets
一些政治事务。所以同样地，我们讨论过，或者也许我们还没讨论过乌拉圭，他卷入了一场那里的短暂战争，有人试图夺回拉普他河上的一座堡垒。他访问了福克兰群岛，他们绕过了麦哲伦海峡。他过着相当优渥的绅士生活。他是什鲁斯伯里人，他就像我一样是个什罗普郡的小伙子。是的，去了剑桥，没见过什么世面。但他，他受到了一种当头棒喝，那就是人类对彼此有着天生的掠夺性。所以在巴塔哥尼亚，他与高乔人交谈，他们吹嘘自己基本上消灭了彭巴斯草原的印第安人，而且他还，他们带了三个人，来自拉丁美洲最南端的火地岛。
involved in kind of political things. So again, we talked about, or maybe we haven't yet talked about Uruguay, and he gets involved in a brief kind of war there there's an attempt to retake a fort on the river plate he visits the Falkland Islands they go around the Midgellan Straits and he's led quite a sheltered life as a gentleman. He's a man from Shrewsbury he's a shop show lad like me. Yeah gone to Cambridge hasn't seen much of the world but he he's kind of brought up short against the way that humans are naturally predacious on each other so he in patagonia he talks to gauchos who who who boast about basically exterminating the indians of the pampas and also he that they they've brought some uh three people Tierra del Fuego at the very bottom of Latin America.
他们把这些人带回英国，并按照英国的启蒙理念教育他们。现在他们正把这些人带回火地岛。结果这些人逃跑了，他们不想像英国人那样生活。他们想回去和自己族人一起生活。达尔文再次被引发了各种关于他所看到的人类不同阶层的思考。所以各种各样的想法在他的脑海中不断涌现。他意识到的事情之一是，当他离开陆地，仍然在使用他的浮游生物网打捞所有这些海洋生物时，令他着迷的是这样一个事实：这里如此丰富，如此美丽。他纳闷，这到底是用来做什么的？因为大多数人，
And they've taken them back to England and kind of educated them according to English lights. And now they're taking them back to Tierra del Fuego. And they run off and they don't want to live as English people. They want to go back and live among their people. And Darwin, again, this provokes him to all kinds of thoughts about the different orders of mankind as he sees it. So all kinds of things are ticking away in his mind. And among the things that he is aware of is that when he's away from the land and he's still using his kind of plankton net to draw up all this marine life. What intrigues him is the fact that it's so rich, it's so beautiful. He wonders, what's it there for? Because most people,
大多数人类根本看不见它们。因此，如果生命的创造是为了让人类赞美，那么所有这些生物在海里究竟在做什麽呢？所以他说：“许多这些生物，在自然等级中如此低下，但其形态却极其精美，色彩极其丰富。这给人一种惊叹的感觉，如此之多的美，表面上看来竟是为了如此微小的目的而创造的。”所以同样，他开始纳闷，为什么不同的生物会存在？它们是如何诞生的？这是一个非常以人类为中心的世界观，不是吗？认为自然的存在只是为了娱乐人类。我觉得这比那更具神学细微差别。我觉得这是，是的，生命的意义是什么？它的目的是什么？它存在的理由是什么？上帝为什么要创造它？
most humans can't see it. So if life has been created to be admired by humans, what are all these creatures doing out in the sea? So he says, many of these creatures, so low in the scale of nature, are most exquisite in their forms and rich colors. It creates a feeling of wonder that so much beauty should be apparently created for such little purpose. So again, he's starting to wonder, why do different organisms exist? How have they come into existence? That's a very anthropocentric view of the world, isn't it? That nature only exists to amuse mankind. I think it's slightly more theologically nuanced than that. I think it's, yeah, what is life for? What's the purpose of it? What does it exist for? Why has God created it?
诸如此类的事情。当他在拉丁美洲四处游历时，他在海里，他在陆地上，他观察着山脉隆起的方式。他去安第斯山脉，他访问了平坦的平原，他在高高的山峰上看到了鱼类的化石，在低地看到了山地生物的化石。他在思考地球的面貌似乎是如何不断塑造的，以及生物是如何诞生并在它们曾栖息的地方消失的。所以所有这些事情都在不断酝酿，他一直在进行日常记录。他在写笔记本。他将这些整理成日记。这就成了航海日志。
All that kind of thing. And as he's going around Latin America, he's at sea, he's on land, he's looking at the way that mountains rise up. He goes to the Andes, he visits at sea, he's on land, he's looking at the way that mountains rise up, he goes to the Andes, he visits flat plains, and he sees fossils of fish high in the mountain peaks, and he sees the fossils of mountain creatures in lowlands. And he's thinking about how the face of the earth seems to constantly be molded and how creatures have come into existence, and then they seem to vanish from the place where they were. So all this kind of stuff is ticking along, and he's keeping constantly be molded and how creatures have come into existence. And then they seem to have vanished from the place where they were. So all this kind of stuff is ticking along and he's keeping a daily log about it. He's writing notebooks. He's building it up into a diary. This becomes a journal.
他在思考地质学与自然历史的关系，以及这两者是如何交织在一起的。一个特定的问题开始隐隐困扰他，就像我猜的，你知道的，喉咙深处开始有点感冒初期的那种刺痒感，那种隐隐的刺痛，是的。关于我们物种恒定性的问题，这就是上帝在时间之初创造了物种的绝对宗教正统观念，而人们的假设是，自那以后，在整个历史进程中它们一直保持不变。是的，达尔文只是开始，这开始让他感到一丝隐忧：实际情况真的是这样吗？正当这个问题让他感到隐隐不安时，“小猎犬号”从拉丁美洲大陆驶向公海，他们抵达了加拉帕戈斯群岛。
And he's thinking about the relationship of geology to natural history and how the two might be interlinked. The particular question is starting to to kind of nudge him a bit like i guess a kind of you know the first onset of a cold at the back of your throat the kind of tickling yeah this question of our species constant which is the absolute religious orthodoxy that god has created species at the beginning of time and the assumption is is that they have remained constant throughout the whole process of time ever since yeah darwin is just kind of start it's starting to niggle at him is that actually the case and it's as he's getting niggled by this question that the beagle sails from mainland Latin America out to sea, and they arrive at the Galapagos Islands.
所以他们显然早就知道加拉帕戈斯群岛的存在。他们当然知道。所以加拉帕戈斯群岛，嗯，我读一下达尔文对它们的描述好吗？好啊。好的，我会的。那太好了。达尔文写道：“这个群岛由十个主要岛屿组成，其中五个岛屿的面积超过其他岛屿。它们位于赤道下方，在美洲西海岸向西 500 到 600 英里之间。”
So they already knew the Galapagos were there, obviously. They absolutely do. So the Galapagos Islands, well, shall I read you Darwin's description of them? Do. Yeah, I will. That'd be lovely. So this archipelago consists of 10 principal islands, Darwin wrote, of which five exceed the others in size. They're situated under the equator and between 500 and 600 miles westward off the coast of America.
它们全部由火山岩构成。少数花岗岩碎片因受热而呈现出奇特的光泽并发生了变质，这几乎不能算作例外。所以它们非常遥远。它们似乎最早是由西班牙人发现的，然后，它们成了英国海盗非常著名的出没地，对吧？然后又成了捕鲸船的聚集地。所以在《怒海争锋》这部电影里，如果你还记得的话，法国人在捕杀英国捕鲸船。实际上是一艘美国捕鲸船在 1818 年发现了这个地方，所以《怒海争锋》里的那个场景是不合时宜的，就像他们打板球的场景一样不合时宜，因为在那部电影里，他们被展示为在进行直臂投球。
They are all formed of volcanic rocks. A few fragments of granite curiously glazed and altered by the heat can hardly be considered as an exception. So they are a long way off. And they seem to have first been discovered by the spanish um and then they uh they become a very popular haunt of english pirates right and and then of whalers yeah so if you remember in master and commander the film yeah the french are preying on english whalers yeah it's actually an american whaler who discovered it in 1818 so that portrait in master and commander is anachronistic as actually is the portrait of them playing cricket because uh in that film they're shown bowling over arm
噢，他们当时应该用下勾手投球的，所以这是另一个错误。噢天哪！所以在 1818 年，一艘美国捕鲸船到达了那里，并发现了数量巨大的抹香鲸，所有的捕鲸船都蜂拥而至。所以，是的，这基本上就是它的用途。但随后在 1832 年，呃，我们现在是 1835 年，所以达尔文已经在海上待了，什么，四年了？所以他在海上待了很长时间。厄瓜多尔于 1832 年将其吞并，他们在其中一个岛屿上建立了一个监狱殖民地，厄瓜多尔人把这个岛叫做弗洛雷亚岛。但管理这个监狱殖民地的家伙是一个名叫尼古拉斯·劳森的英国人。显然，它们作为监狱殖民地堪称完美，因为它们完全是荒岛。
oh they would have been bowling under arm so that's another mistake oh dear so in 1818 an american whaler had had arrived off there and he discovered um this huge number of sperm whales and all the whalers come piling in so yeah that's basically what it's for but then in 1832 so um we're now in 1835 uh so darwin's been at sea for what that's four years so he's been at sea a long time ecuador had annexed in 1832 um and they've on one of the islands an island that the um the ecuadorians callediana, they set up a prison colony. But the guy in charge of this prison colony is an Englishman called Nicholas Lawson. And obviously, they're perfect as a prison colony because they're completely barren.
它们完全与世隔绝。任何罪犯都绝无逃跑的可能。“小猎犬号”于 1835 年 9 月 15 日抵达。我们是不是应该在这个时候休息一下？等我们回来后，我再来描述达尔文看到了什么。真是个悬念啊。他到底会看到什么呢，汤姆？以及从长远来看，这对他的影响。
They're completely isolated. There is no prospect of any convict escaping. So the Beagle arrives on 15th of September, 1835. And should we take a break at this point? And then when we come back, I'll describe what Darwin saw. What a cliffhanger. What's he going to see, Tom? And in the long run, the impact that this has on him.
太棒了。休息过后我们回来，你就会知道达尔文看到了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
Excellent. We'll come back after the break and you'll find out what Darwin saw. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。正如他一贯的做法，汤姆·霍兰把他的故事第一部分停在了一个悬念上。我们不知道查尔斯·达尔文在加拉帕戈斯群岛上会看到什么。汤姆，他看到了什么？好吧，首先，当然，我讲过达尔文在当时主要是一位地质学家。那是他感兴趣的领域。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. As is his want, Tom Holland has ended the first part of his story on a cliffhanger. We don't know what Charles Darwin is going to see on the Galapagos Islands. Tom, what does he see? Well, first off, of course, I talked about how Darwin is preeminently, at this point, a geologist. That's what interests him.
是的。他喜欢各种石头，多米尼克，那才是他感兴趣的。他喜欢各种石头，多米尼克。没错。他喜欢各种石头。我可不喜欢。我的意思是，老实说，对于石头，我可有可无。所以加拉帕戈斯群岛的外观相当阴森。因此，菲茨罗伊在他的日记中写道：“一堆堆黑色、荒凉的碎熔岩，构成了地狱的绝佳去处。”
Yeah. He loves a bit of rock, Domin what interests him. He loves a bit of rock, Dominic. Right. He loves a bit of rock. I'm not. I mean, I can take or leave a rock, if I'm completely honest. So the appearance of the Glaucus is rather grim. So Fitzroy, in his diary, says, a black, dismal-looking heaps of broken lava forming a sure fit for pandemonium.
而达尔文自己也非常精彩地写道，没有什么比初次看到它更让人扫兴的了。呃，然后他把它比作斯塔福德郡的某些地区，斯塔福德郡，是的。然后他接着把它比作伍尔弗汉普顿。伍尔弗汉普顿有许多非常有趣的野生动物，汤姆，我认为这样说挺公平的。但吸引他的不是野生动物，所以他说：“由于规律的形态，众多的火山口，这片土地呈现出一种人造的外观，生动地让我想起了斯塔福德郡那些大型钢铁厂最集中的地方。”所以他想到了工业革命，你知道的，正如你所说，他熟悉内陆地区，所以他把它比作这种工业废墟。如果阿德里安·奇尔斯和诺迪·霍尔德在听的话，他们会对这个比较感到震惊，但你知道的，霍兰家族来自，他们来自特伦特河畔斯托克，他们起源于斯托克，所以
And Darwin himself brilliantly says that nothing could be less inviting than the first appearance and uh he then compares it to regions of staffordshire staffordshire yeah and he then goes on to compare it to wolverhampton well there's a lot of very interesting wildlife from wolverhampton tom i think that's fair to say but it's not the wildlife so he says from the regular form for the many craters they gave to the country an artificial appearance which vividly reminded me of those parts of staffordshire where the great iron foundries are most numerous so he's thinking of the industrial revolution you know he as you said he's familiar with the back country and so he's comparing it to this kind of industrial wasteland if adrian chiles and noddy holder are listening they will be shocked by this comparison but you know the hollands come from um they come from stoke stoke where they originate from so
斯托克，是的，他可能说的是斯托克，我的意思是，斯托克陶器厂众多，对吧？所以他基本上，他看到的是火山锥，其中大多数已经钙化，但他（你知道的）偶尔能看到有一处冒出缕缕青烟，所以他对此非常非常感兴趣。但当然，加拉帕戈斯群岛真正引人注目、闻名于世的是它的野生动物，它们非常非常独特。同样，菲茨罗伊虽然不是自然学家，但他立刻注意到了这一点。他在日记中写道：
stoke yeah it could have been he could have been talking about stoke i mean stoke small potter is though yeah so he's basically what he's looking at is volcanic cones most of them have calcified but he you know there's the odd one where a drift of you know wisps of smoke arising so he's very very interested in that but of course what is really striking about the galapagos island and what it is globally famous for is its wildlife, which is very, very distinctive. And again, Fitzroy, who's not a naturalist, but he immediately notes about it. In his journal, he says, innumerable crabs and hideous iguanas started in every direction
“当我们从一块岩石爬到另一块岩石时，无数的螃蟹和丑陋的鬣蜥从四面八方窜出来。”这听起来很有阿瑟·柯南·道尔的《失落的世界》那种风格，对吧？绝对是的。那些丑陋的鬣蜥。我的意思是，连你也一定能想象出加拉帕戈斯群岛的鬣蜥是什么样子的。它们很大吗？它们体型很大吗？
as we scrambled from rock to rock. So that's very kind of Arthur Conan Doyle, The Lost World or something, isn't it? Absolutely. The hideous iguanas. I mean, even you must be able to picture the iguanas of the Galapagos Islands. Are they enormous? Are they big?
它们可不像《公元前一百万年》里那么大，如果你看过那部电影的话。没错。里面有像威尔士柯基那样受到巨型鬣蜥威胁的场景。但它们确实挺大的。它们的独特性在于它们会游泳。好吧，我觉得这有点让人不安。是的。这是在《怒海争锋》中被提及的一个细节，我想其中一个男孩，那个见习水手，是的，他的手臂被砍掉了，但这没关系，
They're not as big as they are in a million years BC, if you've ever seen that. Right. Where they, like a Welsh guest menace by a giant iguana. But they're pretty large. And what's distinctive about them is that they can swim. Okay, I would find that disturbing. Yeah. That's something that gets picked up in in um master and commander i think one of the boys the little boy the midshipman yeah he's had his arm chopped off but uh it doesn't matter
因为他对自然历史的热爱让他坚持了下来。麦奎恩走过来告诉，是的，是的，走过来告诉马图林鬣蜥在游泳，是的，然后他问“什么？”，接着他们遭到了法国人的攻击，是的。所以保罗·贝坦尼失去了提出进化论的机会。不管怎样，你有鬣蜥。达尔文此时依然对射杀动物非常热衷，他酷爱打猎，但他发现加拉帕戈斯群岛上的野生动物令人失望，因为它们太温顺了。于是他拿着枪，看到了一只鹰，它们一点也不具有威胁性，不是吗？当他看到一只鹰时，他用枪去捅它，是的，而那只鹰只是盯着他看。这根本算不上什么好玩的运动。所以这让达尔文感到失望。
because his love of natural history keeps him going mr blatant comes and tells yeah yes comes and tells maturin that the iguanas are swimming yeah and he goes what and then they get attacked by the french and yeah so so paul bettany is denied the chance to come up with the theory of evolution anyway so you've got the iguanas darwin is still at this point very very keen on shooting things he he loves a hunt but he finds the wildlife on uh the galapagos islands disappointing because it's so tame and so he gets his gun and and he sees a hawk they're very unthreatening aren't they and when he sees a hawk and he pokes it with his gun yeah and the hawk just kind of stares at it this is not good sport at all uh so that's the source of disappointment for darwin and basically
基本上，他把射击的工作交给了他的仆人西姆斯·卡温顿，根据船上的名单，他被招募时是一名小提琴手兼后甲板舱的杂务男孩，对吧？“小猎犬号”从普利茅斯起航时他才 15 岁，所以到这个时候他已经 19 岁了。达尔文利用他来射杀标本，这是唯一的办法，你射杀一个标本，然后把它做成剥制标本，这就是他一直在做的事。有趣的是，他对鬣蜥并不特别感兴趣，因为它们被贴上了大陆物种的标签，被认为是来自大陆的。所以他认为它们没有什么特别有趣的地方。而且他也没有意识到它们会游泳的本领使它们与众不同。
he leaves the the shooting to his his servant sims covington who uh was recruited according to the ship's list as a fiddler and boy to the poop cabin right so he was 15 when the beagle embarked from Plymouth so he's 19 by this point and Darwin is is using him to shoot specimens it's the only way that you can you shoot a specimen and then you stuff it so that's what he's he's doing interestingly he he's not particularly interested in the iguanas because they've been labeled as mainland, as coming from the mainland. So he thinks there's nothing particularly interesting in them. And he doesn't appreciate that their ability to swim makes them distinctive.
所以这是马图林得一分，达尔文得零分。是的。达尔文表现太差了。他没有注意到这一点。然后是乌龟，加拉帕戈斯群岛正是因其而闻名。巨大无比的乌龟，巨大的陆龟。同样，达尔文对它们也不是特别感兴趣，因为他的理论是它们是由英国海盗从印度洋带过来的。
So that's one for Maturin, nil for Darwin. Yeah. Very poor from Darwin. He doesn't notice that. Then there are the tortoises, for which the Galapagos Islands are famous. Huge, giant tortoises, enormous tortoises. And again, Darwin is not particularly interested in them either because his theory is that they have been brought from the Indian Ocean by the English pirates.
因为很显然，如果你是一个出海的水手，乌龟是极好的食物，你只要把它们放下，然后把它们翻个身，接着你就可以吃它们了。所以他对此并不是特别感兴趣。不过，管辖这个惩罚殖民地的英国人劳森曾对他说过一番话，他后来回想起来了。这番话就是，劳森可以从龟壳的形状看出加拉帕戈斯群岛中哪只乌龟来自哪一个不同的岛屿。所以日后，这将成为达尔文关注的一个点。但在当时，他并没有注意到这一点。然后是鸟类。达尔文真正关注的是，那里有嘲鸫。同样，他开始注意到嘲鸫和陆龟一样，因岛屿不同而有所差异。这确实引起了他的兴趣。当这些标本被带回给他时，他根据它们被射杀的岛屿给它们贴上了标签。
Because obviously tortoises make wonderful food if you're a sailor going to sea, you just plonk them on and turn them upside down and then you eat them. So he's not particularly interested in them. But there is a comment that Lawson, who's the Englishman in charge of the penal colony, makes to him that subsequently he will recall. And this comment is that Lawson can tell from which of the various islands of the Galapagos a tortoise comes from the shape of its shell. So in due course, that will be something that Darwin picks up on. But at the time, he doesn't pick up on it. Then there are the birds. And the thing that Darwin really focuses
陆龟因岛屿不同而各异，这确实引起了他的兴趣。当这些标本被射杀、带回给他时，他根据它们被射杀的岛屿给它们贴上标签，对吧，并把它们分开存放。所以他开始有一种感觉：这里也许有什么耐人寻味的东西，这些鸟在每个岛上都不一样，为什么会这样？这怎么能算是一个启示呢？因为达尔文肯定知道，比如说，意大利的动物和英国的动物（或鸟类）是不同的，对吧？或者说，为什么世界不同地区（甚至距离很近的地区）会有略微不同的动植物群，这对他是如此巨大的启示？
in, there are mockingbirds. And again, he starts to notice that the mockingbirds, like the tortoises, differ from island to island. This does interest him. When the specimens are brought back to him, he tags them according to which island they've been shot on. tortoises differ from island to island this does interest him when the specimens are shot brought back to him he tags them according to which island they've been shot on right and keeps them separate so he he's starting to get the sense that maybe there's something intriguing here that these birds are different on each island why is that a revelation because surely darwin must be aware that for example you know there are different animals in Italy than there are in, or birds, than there are in Britain? Or how is this a tremendous revelation to him
因为人们的假设是，这些是在南美洲等地可以找到的鸟类。所以这就是为什么他对鬣蜥不感兴趣，或者南美洲其他地方的动物。所以这就是为什么他对鬣蜥不感兴趣，对世界上其他地方也不感兴趣。这就是为什么他对陆龟不感兴趣。因此，关于嘲鸫的假设也是如此，即存在着由上帝创造的嘲鸫物种，它们本来就是这个样子的。当他开始注意到
that different parts of the world, even in close proximity, will have a slightly different kind of flora and fauna? Because the assumption is that these are birds that can be found, say, in South America. So that's why he's not interested in the guanas, or elsewhere South America. So that's why he's not interested in iguanas or elsewhere in the world. That's why he's not interested in the tortoises. And so the assumption is about the mockingbirds as well, that there is the species of mockingbirds that were created by God, and that's what they're like. When he starts to notice that
加拉帕戈斯群岛上的嘲鸫不仅与大陆上的不同，而且每个岛上的嘲鸫种类也各不相同。这是出乎意料的。他以前从未近距离见过这种情况。这很不寻常。种类繁多的丰富性。正是这一点给他留下了深刻的印象。是的。所以，这并不是说他一看到这一点，就立刻提出了进化论，这也许是关于达尔文和加拉帕戈斯群岛的陈词滥调。事情并非如此。甚至也不是说，这给他留下了某种深刻的洞察。这只是，这只是一个有趣且意料之外的事情，值得记录下来，值得详加描述。这里还有雀鸟，非常非常多种类的雀鸟，大量的小型鸟类。
not only are the mockingbirds on the Galapagos Islands different from the ones on the mainland, but that the different kind of mockingbird on each island is different. That's something unexpected. He hasn't seen this up close before. That's unusual. The sheer variegated nature of the variety. That's what impresses itself upon him. Yes. So it's not like he sees this and he immediately comes up with the theory of evolution, which is perhaps the kind of the cliche about Darwin and the Galapagos Islands. That's not what happens. And it's not even like, you know, it strikes him as a kind of great insight. It's just, it's something interesting and unexpected that is worth recording and worth making, worth detailing. There are also finches, lots and lots of different kinds of finches, lots and lots of small birds.
他的仆人卡温顿射杀了大量这种鸟。它们非常非常温顺。他把它们留了下来，但他发现很难把它们区分开来。许多雀鸟看起来几乎一模一样。因此达尔文写道：“羽毛的解释几乎是一模一样，鸟类的习性也无法区分，因为它们一起在庞大而不规则的群落中觅食。”你知道的，他正坐着，卡温顿给他带回了所有这些雀鸟，达尔文正坐在“小猎犬号”的船舱里试图分辨它们，基本上他双手一摊，说他做不到，因为所有这些标本只构成了一种莫名其妙的混杂，他称之为混杂。
And Covington, his servant, shoots vast numbers of these birds. They're very, very tame. He keeps them, but he finds it very, very difficult to tell them apart. Lots of these finches look pretty identical. And so Darwin writes, an explanation of the plumage was almost identical nor were the birds habits distinguishable for they feed together in large irregular flocks and you know he's sitting covington is bringing him back all these kind of finches darwin is sitting in in his um cabin in the beagle trying to work them out and basically he he throws his hands up and says he can't because all these specimens just form an inexplicable confusion, he calls them.
但同样，关于雀鸟，雀鸟的多样性，有些东西让他觉得非常奇怪。所以，这并不是说他在说：“哇，这里有件了不起的事情，我需要解释一下。也许通过自然选择的进化论可以解释它。”事情并不是这样的。但话说回来，回到那个比喻，这就像是喉咙深处的刺痒。这是一种值得思考的奇怪事物的直觉。所以他们基本上在那里呆了几个星期。他们并没有呆很长时间。然后他们启航横渡太平洋。他们前往大溪地。正是在途中，正是在途中，达尔文真正开始，他正在观察嘲鸫。他把它们按不同的
But again, there is something about the finches, the variety of the finches, that strikes him as being very curious. So again, it's not like he's saying, wow, there's something amazing here that I need to explain. Maybe theory of evolution by natural selection would explain it. That's not what happens. But again, to go back to that analogy, it's a tickling at the back of his throat. It's the sense of something odd that is worth considering. So they're just basically there for a couple of weeks. They're not there for very long. And then they set off across the Pacific. They head to Tahiti. And on the way, it's on the way that Darwin really starts to kind of, he's looking at the mockingbirds. He's put them into different groups according to different
岛屿分成了不同的群。他真的、真的很着迷于这样一个事实，比如说，来自一个岛屿的鸟类和另一个岛屿的鸟类，它们之间存在着一些微小的差异。他对此反复琢磨，反复思考。这只会增加他对物种稳定性产生的怀疑，因为这意味着，如果这些鸟类来到了加拉帕戈斯群岛，并且它们，你知道的，去了不同的岛屿，而且它们在每个岛上都各不相同，那么这其中的含义也许就是，它们随着时间的推移发生了改变。难道他在离开英国之前没有阅读过任何能助长这种想法或将其中一些观点植入他脑海的书籍吗？因为关于达尔文究竟是真正的第一人，还是从其他人那里得到了灵感，存在着一定程度的历史争论，不是吗？嗯，有伊拉斯谟·达尔文。所以这在家族里。是的，这种思想一直在酝酿。但达尔文如果没有登上“小猎犬号”，很可能会成为一名牧师。所以这其中有某种宗教层面的因素，当然会给他带来困扰。不管怎样，他们继续航行，最后回到了英国。达尔文拥有所有这些，你知道的，他拥有他的收藏品。他在拉丁美洲得到的所有收藏品，他都通过另一艘船寄回了英国。但加拉帕戈斯雀鸟，加拉帕戈斯嘲鸫，所有这些他带来的标本，他在整个航行过程中都随身携带。
islands. And he's really, really intrigued by the fact that, say, the birds from one island and another, that there are kind of little differences in them. And he's pondering this and pondering this. And it's just kind of adding to his doubts about the stability of species because the implication is that if these birds have got the Galapagos Islands and they've you know they've gone to different islands and yeah they're different on each island then perhaps the implication of that is that they have changed over the course of time and he hasn't been reading anything in Britain before he left that has fueled this or has put some of these ideas in his head? Because there's some degree of historical debate, isn't there, about whether Darwin is genuinely the
因此，在 1837 年 1 月 4 日，他将这些呈交给伦敦动物学会。其中有 80 种哺乳动物和 450 种不同类型的鸟类。天哪！这其中就包括那些达尔文基本上双手一摊、说他根本无法理解的雀鸟，而达尔文（你知道的）对它们并不是特别感兴趣，他，他依然对它们感到困惑，因为他还没有真正搞懂它们，而且他甚至没有把它们全部识别为雀鸟——他认为其中一些是鹪鹩，他认为其中一些是画眉鸟的亲戚——所以他确实根本没有搞清楚它们。他当然也没有意识到，
first or whether he's getting ideas from other people? Well, there's Erasmus Darwin. So it's in the family. Yes, it is bubbling away there. But Darwin, had he not gone on the Beagle, would probably have become a clergyman. And so there are kind of religious dimensions to this that will, of course, trouble him. Anyway, so on they sail and they end up back in Britain. And Darwin has all this, you know, he has his collection. All the collection he got in Latin America, he'd sent back to England via another ship. But the Galapagos finches, the Galapagos mockingbirds, all these specimens that he's brought, he's got them with him throughout
所有这些实际上都是雀鸟的不同种类的鸟类可能是密切相关的。他并没有掌握这一点。于是他把它们交给了动物学会。它们的标签贴得很糟糕。他把一些雀鸟标成了鹪鹩，你知道的，诸如此类。然而幸运的是，有一个人非常适合梳理所有这些标本并弄清它们的头绪，这个人叫约翰·古尔德。与达尔文不同，他不是一个绅士，实际上他是，呃，一个园丁的儿子，他以制作剥制标本为生，所以他是动物学会的动物剥制师，呃，“动物保护者”是他的官方头衔。
the entire voyage. And so he, on the 4th of January, 1837, he presents these to the London Zoological Society. And there are 80 mammals and there are 450 different types of birds. Crikey. And among these are the finches that basically basically darwin had thrown his hand up and said i can't make any sense of this and darwin is you know he's not particularly interested in them um he he remains confused by them he since he hasn't really got a handle on them um and he hasn't even identified all of them as finches so he thinks that some of them are wrens he thinks some of them are relatives of blackbirds um so he's really not got on top of them at all. And he certainly doesn't have a sense
所以他的报酬并不算特别丰厚，但他是一位非常非常杰出的鸟类学家，这是他的挚爱，你知道的，当这些雀鸟被送到他手里时，他正坐在动物学会的办公室里制作标本，是的，他被它们深深吸引了，以至于他暂停了那些有报酬的工作，开始试图弄清楚所有这些不同的鸟到底是什么。他很快意识到，实际上，那些鹪鹩等等，那些画眉鸟，所有这些其实都是雀鸟。他花了，
that all these different kinds of birds that are in fact finches might be closely related. He's not on top of that. And so he hands them over to the Zoological Society. They're very badly labeled. He's labeled some finches he's labeled some wrens you know so on however fortunately there is a guy who's perfectly suited to going through all these specimens and making sense of them this is a guy called john gould who unlike darwin is not a gentleman so he is actually um the son of a gardener um he makes a living as a taxidermist so he's the um the taxidermist for the uh for the zoological society right the animal preserver is his official name
基本上花了一个星期的时间研究它们，进行了六天集中研究，到最后他已经意识到它们是 13 种不同的雀鸟。不久之后，他会意识到达尔文编目为鹪鹩的第三种鸟，
um so he's not hugely well paid but he's a very very brilliant ornithologist this is his great love and you know he's he's sitting in uh the offices of the zoological society stuffing things when these finches get delivered to him yeah and he's so intrigued by them that he pauses the work for which he's being paid and starts trying to to work out what all these different birds are and he rapidly realizes that actually the wrens and so on um the blackbirds that all of them are finches and and he spends um basically a week studying them six days concentrated work and by the end he has he has realized that they are 12 distinct species of finch and in due course he will realize that a third one that darwin had catalogued as a wren,
其实也是一种雀鸟。总共有 13 种不同的雀鸟。坦白跟你说，汤姆，我不明白这怎么算是一个戏剧性的突破……我的意思是，谁在乎呢？我的意思是，也许我不是个观鸟者，或者确实，我对科学一无所以。所以请向我解释一下这为什么令人兴奋。
that that is also a finch. So 13 different species of finch in all. I'll be frank with you, Tom. I don't understand why this is a dramatic breakthrough in... I mean, who cares? I mean, maybe I'm not a birder, or indeed, I have no knowledge of science at all. So explain to me why this is exciting so perhaps it's moderately interesting if you're interested in birds for their own sake yeah that they're all these new species of finch yeah brilliant you know you're a fan of the finch i love finches can't get enough of them you love a finch you can't get enough of them this is great but for darwin yeah it sharpens the question that his analysis of the mockingbirds,
所以，如果你纯粹因为喜欢鸟类而对鸟类感兴趣的话，这可能算得上是温和的有趣，是的，有这么多新的雀鸟物种，是的，太棒了，你知道的，你是个雀鸟迷，我太喜欢雀鸟了，百看不厌。你喜欢雀鸟，百看不厌，这太棒了。但对于达尔文来说，这加剧了一个问题，即他对嘲鸫的分析，
and then remembering what Lawson, the prison governor, had said about the tortoises. Oh, the shells, yeah. The different kinds of shells. The problem is, how do you explain that each island has a distinct species? In other words, what is the process by which that might have happened? Did God create? Is it best to be explained by the idea that, yes, that God creates the Galapagos Islands, and he decides each island will have its own distinct species of finch?
然后回想起监狱长劳森对陆龟的评价。哦，龟壳，是的。不同种类的龟壳。问题在于，你该如何解释每个岛屿都有一个独特的物种？换句话说，这可能是通过什么过程发生的？是上帝创造的吗？最好用这种观点来解释吗：是的，上帝创造了加拉帕戈斯群岛，并且他决定每个岛屿都有其独特的雀鸟物种？
Yeah. Or is it evidence of speciation? In other words, a species of finch gets blown across the seas from the mainland, and they land on different islands and they start to adapt to the different situation that you get on each island and the thing that's absolutely key to this is the beaks because the beaks oh right okay each species of finch yeah has a different kind of beak and the beak is proportionate to you know whatever the nuts or whatever it is the trees the plant life that you need to to get your your food if you're a finch okay so the beak is is perfectly adapted
是的。还是说这是物种形成的证据？换句话说，某种雀鸟物种被大风从大陆吹过海洋，它们降落在不同的岛屿上，并开始适应你在每个岛屿上遇到的不同情况。而这其中绝对关键的东西就是鸟喙，因为鸟喙，哦，对了，好的！每一种雀鸟，是的，都有不同种类的鸟喙，而鸟喙与（不管是什么坚果还是别的什么）树木、植物相匹配，如果你是一只雀鸟，这些是你获取食物所需要的，好的！所以鸟喙被完美地适应了，
as though it had been designed tom well as though it had been designed although or perhaps it has been selected by natural means would be the alternative theory. And so this is the theory that Darwin starts to ponder. And in 1839, so that's a couple of years after he's got back and presented his finches to the Zoological Society, he publishes what he calls his journal remarks. It will be reissued and is more famously known as the voyage of the beagle. And he writes in that about the, about the beaks that the finches on the Galapagos islands, that it is very remarkable that a nearly perfect gradation of structure in this
就好像它是被设计好的一样，汤姆。嗯，就好像它是被设计好的一样，不过或者也许它是通过自然选择被挑选出来的，这会是另一种理论。所以这就是达尔文开始深思的理论。在 1839 年，也就是他回到英国并将雀鸟呈交给动物学会的几年后，他出版了他所谓的《日记札记》。这本书后来被重新发行，更为人熟知的名字是《小猎犬号航海记》。他在书中写到了关于加拉帕戈斯群岛雀鸟的鸟喙：
one group can be traced in the form of the beak from one exceeding in dimensions out of the largest grow beak to another differing, but little from that of a warbler and this isn't the conclusive proof for a theory of evolution by natural selection but it's a it's a very very neat illustration of it and when in 1845 um this this journal gets published again under the title of the voyage of the beagle dar. Darwin is, again, he's testing the waters more boldly. And he writes, seeing this gradation and diversity of structure in one small, intimately related group of birds, one might really fancy that from an original paucity of birds in this archipelago,
“非常引人注目的是，在这个单一的群体中，几乎完美的结构渐变可以从鸟喙的形状中追踪出来，从一个尺寸超过最大主喙的鸟喙，到另一个与莺鸟的鸟喙相差无几的鸟喙。”这虽然不是通过自然选择进化论的确凿证据，但它是一个非常非常巧妙的例证。当在 1845 年，呃，这本日志再次以《小猎犬号航海记》为题出版时，达尔文再次更为大胆地试水。他写道：“看到这群紧密相关的单一小型鸟类群体的结构渐变和多样性，人们真的会产生一种幻想，即从这个群岛最初稀少的鸟类中，
one species had been taken and modified for different ends. So the passive voice there had been taken i mean it leaves it open that perhaps god had done this but it's also leaving open the possibility that there might be some other explanation for it and again he hints very strongly at what this might be because he says he writes both in space and time we seem to be brought somewhat near to that great fact that mystery of mysteries the first appearance of new beings on the earth and you get the sense that you know he's he's nervous because he knows how sensitive how in fact how explosive this theory may prove to be and when in due course he comes to write The Origin of Species and to publish it, the finches are on the Galapagos Islands feature. And so the role that the Galapagos Islands plays
取出了一个物种，并为了不同的目的对它进行了改造。”所以那里的被动语态“被取出”——我的意思是，它留下了这样一种开放性：也许是上帝做了这件事，但它同时也开放了这样一种可能性：可能还有其他某种解释。而且，他再次强烈暗示了这可能是什么，因为他写道：“无论是在空间还是时间上，我们似乎都有些接近那个伟大的事实——万物之谜——新生命在地球上的首次出现。”你会有一种感觉，你知道的，他很紧张，因为他知道这个理论可能会被证明是多么敏感，甚至具有多么大的爆炸性。当他在适当的时候开始撰写《物种起源》并将其出版时，加拉帕戈斯群岛的雀鸟成为了其中的特色。因此，加拉帕戈斯群岛所扮演的角色
is always recognized and acknowledged. But I think the reason that it plays this kind of key role in, if you like, the mythology of Darwinism is the fact that if you want a kind of physical portrayal of how evolution works how the theory of natural selection functions you have fossils so the classic one is gradations of horse evolving over the course of geological time another one is whales palaeontologists have found uh the land animal that becomes the marine animal and you can kind of trace the progress. But if you want living animals, the beaks of those finches are pretty good. And so they've come to be called Darwin's finches because they're emblematic of the theory that he comes up with. But I think that the myth is that he goes to the Galapagos Islands and he comes up with the theory of evolution, of bionatural selection. That's not true.
一直以来都得到了解和认可。但我认为，它之所以能在达尔文主义的神话中扮演这样一个核心角色，原因在于，如果你想要一个关于进化如何运作、自然选择理论如何发挥作用的物理写照，化石就是现成的。最经典的例子就是地质年代中马的演化过渡，另一个是鲸鱼，古生物学家已经发现了陆地动物变成海洋动物的过程，你可以追踪到这种演变。但如果你想要活生生的动物，那些雀鸟的喙就非常合适。因此，它们被称为“达尔文雀”，因为它们成了他提出的理论的象征。但我觉得这其中的神话在于，人们认为他去了加拉加帕斯群岛，然后就想出了进化论和生物自然选择的理论。事实并非如此。
It's a much longer process. But it is, you know, they play an important role in the theory that he will come to. If you compress that story, there's a line, you're drawing a line from his arrival in the Galapagos to him publishing The Origin of Species all those years later. Because there's quite a long interval, isn't there? There is. Between his return and then publishing the theory. And Steve Jones writes brilliantly on Darwin. I mean, he has written about how actually it's the stuff that Darwin sees in England
这是一个漫长得多的过程。但它们确实在他最终得出的理论中扮演了重要角色。如果你把这个故事压缩，你就会把一条线从他抵达加拉帕斯群岛联系到他多年后出版《物种起源》。因为这中间有一段相当长的间隔，对吧？确实如此。在他返回和随后出版该理论之间。史蒂夫·琼斯写过关于达尔文的精彩文章。我的意思是，他写过其实是达尔文在英国看到的东西
once he's got back from the voyage of the Beagle that's just as important, if not more important, on influencing all his stuff with worms and all his stuff that he's doing it down house and so on but that's that's as important it's not as good a story though is it tom let's be honest not as good a story no it's not and also don't you think the galapagos have this they play an outsized part in this story partly because the galapagos have this sort of in the in the popular imagination they're the garden of eden aren't they untouched you know unspoiled untouched um a sort of vision of
在他从“小猎犬号”航行归来后，这些东西同样重要，甚至更重要，它们影响了他关于蚯蚓的所有研究，以及他在唐豪斯进行的所有研究等等。但这些同样重要，不过它的故事性没那么好，对吧，汤姆？老实说，故事性没那么好。不，确实不好。而且，难道你不觉得加拉帕斯群岛在这场故事中扮演了过分重要的角色吗？部分原因在于，在公众的想象中，加拉帕斯群岛就像是伊甸园，不是吗？未受触碰的，未受污染的，未受破坏的，一种对……的愿景
paradise that's still the way that they are sold to tourists today i mean it's interesting you say they're sold as the garden of eden and paradise because of course you know the bits i read make it sound like hell well if you don't like wolverhampton i mean well fitzroy is just calling it pandemonium you know the the word from milton's paradise lost yeah uh the the vision of of hell that it's black rock smoke inhabited by fearsome monsters but that for us has now become yes as you say a kind of vision of paradise and the environmental stresses that the galapagos islands are under are seen as you know globally as a kind of temperature check on the state of biodiversity absolutely yeah yeah so there we go ecuador fascinating story tom and i think you've done tremendous justice to the richness and
这仍然是今天向游客推销它们的方式。我的意思是，你说它们被当作伊甸园和天堂来推销，这很有意思，因为当然，我读到的那些片段让它听起来像地狱一样。如果你不喜欢伍尔弗汉普顿的话……费茨罗伊直接称它为混乱之地，你知道的，这个词出自弥尔顿的《失乐园》。对，那种地狱的景象——那里是黑色的岩石、烟雾，居住着可怕的怪物。但对我们来说，现在它已经变成了，正如你所说的一种天堂的愿景。加拉帕斯群岛目前所承受的环境压力，被全球视为生物多样性现状的一种“温度计”。绝对是的，所以这就是厄瓜多尔，一个迷人的故事，汤姆，我认为你非常公正地展现了厄瓜多尔历史的丰富性与
sophistication of ecuador's history and um no no it's a i'm kidding it's a it's a genuinely fascinating story and i say that as somebody who's not saying that some you know you you love your science i'm not really into science it's fair to say but um well i what i don't like about so i don't like abstract nouns basically and um i think what's lovely about the darwin story is that it humanizes it and it places it in time um which i do like i thought um i thought you did that sir i thought you did that beautifully tom i don't often say that to you on this podcast. Thank you very much. I'm sure that specialists in the theory of evolution listening to this, I apologize if I got any of that wrong. I think the outline is basically right.
复杂性，呃，不，不，我开玩笑的，这确实是一个真正迷人的故事。我作为一个对科学……怎么说呢，你热爱科学，但我其实并不怎么懂科学，这么说挺公平的。不过，我不喜欢抽象名词，基本上就是这样。我认为达尔文故事可爱的地方在于，它将其人格化了，并把它置于特定的时间里，这正是我喜欢的。我认为你做得非常出色，汤姆，我在这档播客里可不常这么夸你。非常感谢。我相信收听这期节目的进化论专家们，如果我有任何讲错的地方，我在此致歉。但我认为总体的大纲基本上是正确的。
Tom, we're a podcast, we're not a monograph. Exactly. We're not Radio 3. So that's Ecuador. And on that bombshell, we will see you tomorrow for something else goodbye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
汤姆，我们是一档播客，我们不是学术专著。没错。我们可不是BBC第三台。这就是厄瓜多尔的故事。伴随着这个重磅消息，我们明天见，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。每周为您带来娱乐新闻、评论、少许八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。